you needed a certain full stack engineer
with node and react uh
to work out of your office you you might
see five or ten resumes you don't need
any ai for that you don't need any
sophisticated automatic web button for
that
now uh suppose you're thrown in this
situation where uh you're
you're willing to say well i'll hire the
best person in the world wherever they
are
now now you have 5000 people what are
you going to do with that
what are you going to do with that
[Music]
vijay krishnan thank you for joining me
on 20 minute leaders i'm so honored to
have you here
are you in palo alto now uh i am michael
yes
thanks for inviting me what wonderful no
no thank you for
for being here your journey is so
fascinating and there's so much to talk
about
i want to talk about your experience in
iit and
at stanford i want to talk about being
at yahoo then rover
selling your company rover and then now
being
the cto of touring which is doing i
think phenomenal things that are so
so relevant for this upcoming decade as
we're seeing a surge of
of remote software developers and
whether it's hiring onboarding and
really trying to understand
how do we get to the top one percent uh
so i've talked already way too much
vijay tell me a little bit about
yourself all the way back from bombay
how do you go through your journey sure
sure
so uh i
got started in the field of ai and
machine learning rather early i think i
have been at it for
uh something like 18 years now uh uh on
your
wow a lot longer than uh
certainly from uh it wasn't uh as
cool or as hot at that specific point
but
uh so um yeah i i started working on
such problems all the way
back from my days at iit bombay then at
stanford university and
then even as a scientist at yahoo where
i mostly
focused on research publications uh
patents things of
that sort it was in my previous
uh startup that i first applied a lot of
these methods to
commercial problems like my previous
problem uh
company rover did personalized content
recommendations and uh
so in other words we would figure out
what topics you like
based on the kind of content you consume
and recommend other content you may like
that company got acquired about four
years back and
in the course of running my past startup
we had
accidentally stumbled into a lot of
these insights
that would eventually uh set the stage
for us starting a company like turing
since we had worked with some
really exceptional software engineers
from different uh parts of the world
like uh when we found it challenging to
scale our
silicon valley a team with the same
high standards that we always maintained
we uh
we looked to other countries so we ended
up working with a distributed team of
engineers in russia
ukraine poland serbia china and so on we
somehow
managed to wow get that team to work and
uh
doing a lot of things by trial and error
figuring out how to uh
effectively source and uh screen and uh
ultimately uh did i gain a lot of
ongoing benefits by working with the
very best engineers around the world
gave us a lot of imp valuable insights
so when
when it was time to start a new company
often you you want to check off a bunch
of boxes
first of all is the market really large
is the problem really valuable but there
is a there are also some last uh there's
a last point
which is to do with are you uniquely the
founders who are suitable for starting
such a company
do you have certain insights and
understanding which far surpass the most
most other smart people you know and
the turing idea checked off the last
point also in addition to all the other
ones
and uh making this is the right company
for us to start
vj we could go on for hours now so i'm
really gonna have to to restrain myself
over here first take me back 18 years
i i didn't hear machine learning and ai
18 years ago in fact i didn't hear much
of it even 12 years ago
how do you you're in bombay first of all
it's incredible that you went to iit i
believe that acceptance rate is
something
just above three percent so so i i we're
going to skip over that right now but
but tell me a little bit about your your
growing up your upbringing and
why why ai 18 years ago yeah yeah
yeah the the acceptance rate i think is
a lower than a percent but uh but yes
speaking of
well at that point the the thing is i
think uh
i was very uh i suppose
uh interested in
in probability and statistics and a lot
of things around mathematical modeling
and
so on what i liked about machine
learning is is that it also had a lot of
nice commercial applications like there
was a
i remember uh having this uh
conversation
with my uh dad where uh back in my
undergraduate days where i was
telling him well i really like this
mathematical stuff and i'm thinking of
going into you know graph algorithms and
some purely theoretical stuff my dad was
like no
you you probably won't get a job if you
if you go down that area
think of something more practical and uh
machine learning i love that
and machine learning sort of uh i i like
the fact that it had the mathematical
depth it
it satisfied those sort of uh
intellectual this thing uh curiosities
and other things i had by while also
at that point of course it was it had
nowhere the
practical applications that it had uh
now but i i love the fact that it could
solve a lot of
problems that were that could not be
solved by by any other means a lot of
things to do with the text
classification
email classification into spam or not
spam topical
text classification all these were very
much possible a good 20 years back
and other problems to do with nlp and so
on though some
at that point a vast majority of the
most important nlp problems weren't
easily solvable but a
subset of them were and i i generally uh
like the fact that there was this nice
combination of both the
theoretical depth as well as practical
application even at that point
right so before we dive into touring and
what you're doing over there
i want to talk a little bit about
building great teams and and i think
part of the
the journey that you're talking about
here and part of the insights that
you've gained into touring is that
you know there are different ways to
building a great team the way that we
build great teams in 2021
is very different than how we build
teams in 2010 and you've heart you've
harnessed that insight through having
that distributed team
and we have companies like git lab i
believe that are fully distributed right
from the get-go
so the world is changing but before all
that you're starting a startup
you you think you have an idea that is
worth pursuing
as the cto as the chief technology
officer
what is your responsibility in scaling
the team and getting the right software
engineers on board
is it what are some of the biggest
challenges or excitements around that
uh are you asking specifically in the
context
of my challenges in the context of
turing or ctos in general
uh in the context of well i'd love to
hear from you
from your journey what are some things
that perhaps other
young ctos should keep in mind as they
go and they skill the team because
obviously
it's one thing to take your two three
best friends from stanford and build
something right but then
you want to get to 10 20 100 engineers
so how do you do that
right right no the it's a so it's a
great question i think we have certainly
had to
uh think through a lot of things from
first principles in the context of a
startup like
for example if all you're doing uh
obviously
you don't need to invent each and
everything from first principles
in a company there are there are a lot
of things you can simply borrow by way
of
best practices but there are a lot of
important things uh cert and
hiring is certainly one of them where it
is very very important
that you have your own thesis you you
think uh
long and hard regarding what is uh
suitable for your company and not just
for engineers i would even say this is
for
true of various other roles particularly
where a certain amount of
technical depth is necessary for example
at tuning we do a lot of things very
unconventionally
for example uh our
growth marketing efforts and uh many of
those other things report to me they
don't report to a traditional
cmo and in large measures really yes
this is again
because of our obsession with the data
science part of these things as a
as a way to drive results so we have a
lot of
counter there are enough areas where we
disagree with the world at large and you
might have even heard of
facebook for example recently taking the
position
that uh i believe it was their vp of
marketing or their cmo or somebody who
came from the classic
growth marketing track that was
more the data science kind of track
rather than the pr kind of track
so yeah generally ultimately i mean
you you accomplish great things in uh in
a company by
uh in large part hiring the best people
uh now
this this this cannot just be achieved
by looking at well who's the
what company is doing something similar
today let's just hire uh
people out of those and do the exact
same thing they are uh doing that is not
going to
get you a 10x better result like one
thing people often say in the context of
a company is you you better be 10x
better than the competition
to blaze through the market otherwise
you're going to have a hard time selling
and uh
yeah so
this is certainly something we've given
a lot of thought and i encourage
everyone
to do this i i'm still inspired by that
single sentence
that you know we were obsessed with
using data to to
to make to to make everything that
you're to reach all your matrix right
and i think that that obsession
and obviously coming from your
background i can understand how you how
you truly understand the value of what
you're doing
and and i think that in a world where a
lot of these words are are getting
thrown out
quite extensively actually being
intentional on being obsessed with the
data
to to have that growth and i i love the
the fact that your growth marketing
reports to the cto and not to the
marketing division because it is at the
end it's it's all about
using the data so so talk to me a little
bit about this idea of
vetting for greatness right that is one
of the the headlines in your on your
website
vetting for greatness for remote
software developers
first of all what is the problem why do
we even need to
have another vetting system today
yeah i think the uh the main issue is
that
today uh for most part the whole hiring
process itself is quite
manual uh there are a few tools which do
a narrow set of things like administered
a programming test or something like
that but we all know that that is a
small
uh a portion of
what a software developer needs to be
good at to ultimately be
effective in a role so uh the
so i think there's a couple of different
things here i think remote particularly
makes
makes it a lot lot more important that
we get this right because with
uh with remote there is a uh there's an
opportunity but that opportunity
creates some new uh new challenges along
the way the opportunity is
that once you remove the zip code
constraint
your theoretical pool of candidates is
quite enormous
so for for example suppose you uh you
needed a certain full stack engineer
with node and react
to work out of your office you you might
see five or ten resumes you don't need
any ai for that you don't need any
sophisticated automatic web version for
that
now uh suppose you're thrown in this
situation where uh you'll be
you're willing to say well i'll hire the
best person in the world wherever they
are
no no you have 5000 people what are you
going to do with that
how do you what are you going to do with
that yeah and uh i i i think that is
where
a lot of things around the automation
become really valuable
to uh to um to leverage the fact that
you
suddenly have this giant pool of
pool of software developers many of them
live in
countries and in cities where you can't
make any sense of their resume in the
sense you
today be all of us use proxies i would
say this the
this person went to stanford this was
this person worked at google this person
worked at this other startup that i know
has higher hiring standards
people use all sorts of shortcuts for
quality to uh
to engage in some form of shortlisting
such such things
don't work very well uh when you're
tapping into talent from all over the
world and uh so at that point you one
has to have a good automated waiting
process like a turing
the uh the uh we not only wet for
programming skill that a few other
platforms
do we also do computer science
fundamentals we do various uh tech
stacks
so what uh how strong are you in
specific technologies like
node and react uh or in graphql
how good are you as a communicator now
this is in terms of
raw english fluency and also in terms of
i guess how easy is it to have a good
technical discussion with you where you
understand the gist of
where something is going and what the
other person wants
and very closely related to some of
these are matters
uh to do with uh what is this person's
product and business sense like
obviously the the higher that is the
more autonomously a software developer
would be able to operate
so we we test for a lot of such things
to create a pretty uh
to create a deep developer profile
but far far in excess of what one could
possibly glean from a resume
and use that to make much better matches
so so walk me through the customer
journey here so if i'm if i'm hiring for
software engineers i need
you know i needed a data scientist to re
a front-end engineer and i need a
you know a dba and now where i i you
know i'm opening myself up to the world
because it's 2021 it doesn't really
matter where i'm at in the world i want
the best people
and oftentimes you know people that are
farther away might even be cheaper
than the ones that are closer to me so
then how does it actually work what is
the journey here
well when somebody comes to uh
tuning the journey for them is fairly
straightforward they simply sign up for
turing turing has already done all the
work
and uh from the customer's perspective
the customer gets to uh review a few
developer profiles
can tell us if they would like to do a
video calls with
any of them if they do like one or more
of them
uh they can they can start working with
them and we anyway offer this
two-week no risk trial where if a
customer um
starts working with the developer and uh
decides to stop for any reason in under
two weeks they pay nothing
uh so a lot of them yeah yeah yes
in many ways that's just a reflection of
our confidence in our
match quality course yeah so uh
there are certainly occasions where the
uh where we mismatch but those are a
very small percentage
uh so so that is the thing now if you
had to do the whole thing from scratch
well you i mean you could you know you
could scrounge around i mean
obviously recruiting existed before
turing other people will
attempt to do their own in-house
recruiting but the point is you
uh there is there are certainly
uh if i mean
in the in the most extreme case one
would have to do uh everything we do at
turin with regard to generating a giant
uh
uh uh giant pipeline uh doing a whole
bunch of other things to uh to make this
uh happen it uh and you already have
more than 200 000 developers that are
registered so as a company obviously
coming to you i'm already seeing this
you already have a data mode
of this incredible pool of developers
and and your ability to then match me so
i i love the first of all i love the
fact that you're you know you have first
of all the
two-sided marketplace that you've
already solved one side of it you have
them
and now the more i give up myself the
more you get to know me the better
you'll match me with those two hundred
thousand and it's really it's as if i'm
getting two hundred thousand resumes
and you're telling me okay michael and
here are the top ones for you and now
tell me a little bit about this about uh
you know the culture because
culture has been a significant part of
you know silicon valley's journey i
think in the last three four years
every other article on entrepreneur.com
and forbes talks about the
culture whether it's good usually bad
how do you think you know this remote
work
and inevitably we're moving to uh you
know
99 of the workforce will be remote i
think you know within 10 15 years
how what is what is the impact this is
going to have on culture especially as a
chief technology officer
amongst developers which are you know
innately not the most
culture you know extravagant
personalities
so yeah i i i i i think
the the the question you ask is a very
very good one so
there is definitely a sense in which i
think in a um
in a remote first uh world there is
definitely a sense in which
developers will will need to be uh more
uh i mean will will need to
sort of be more uh extrovert ish
compared to
what they might have been able to get
away with i mean even in
um you know even in an in-office
environment we all know this ultimately
from the standpoint of growing uh
from the standpoint of uh doing uh more
collaborations getting promoted and all
those other things
it does become quite challenging if a
developer is not sufficiently
extroverted i mean
ultimately developers much like
everybody else do wish to
grow as individuals uh assume more
responsibility and do more valuable
things and everything
so i think in in remote certainly that
is one of the things we
uh we both test for among our developers
that is certainly something we take into
account when uh
when deciding uh if they should be hired
and matched to a job
and that is also something that we uh we
nudge developers very strongly toward
for example today we have a
collaboration product that turing
developers use
which basically uh constantly nudges
developers in the direction of over
communication so our product
ensures that developers do these virtual
daily standups uh
do something like uh short uh weekly
plans which all get emailed to a manager
uh that a manager can sort of uh um so
it's quite lightweight to use for a
manager
but and the manager can sort of uh
intervene and call for a meeting or
something if they sort of disagree with
some of the plans on the roadmap
the primary uh objective of this is to
ensure that the developer doesn't go off
on their own tangent for a couple of
weeks and then
the manager is like well uh this was not
what i had in mind or
this was not worthy of this this time
investment or something like
that yeah but uh there is no question
over communication is vital in uh in uh
in the setting i mean
in all sorts of things in fact i think
this is something we are still
discovering we are still discovering how
to do happy hours
how to do parties and all that like i
know zoom supposedly has breakout rooms
this is still something
uh the i'm trying to figure out
how to do within tuning the sort of
thing where you invite 50 people to a
virtual party but then
also have these groups right where
groups of four or five can chat then you
uh you move on the same thing that you
would do in a real party
well you know if you had to ask me for a
prediction i think that you know we're
not going to get
that we're not going to we're what we're
seeing now is a huge opportunity and gap
in the market where we have
this incredibly accelerated pool of
of software engineers and really the
remote workforce in general moving
remotely that's you know
that's done some will come back to the
offices they'll slowly transition out
understanding that talent can be found
everywhere so definitely in our industry
we're going to be
seeing a lot more than we also see today
but
i think that there's still a huge gap on
the experience in the culture and i
think they're actually the the virtual
reality and augmented reality which
haven't found a marketplace
until today we've we've been seeing
growing technology but they haven't
really found a place because
we didn't need it because we were still
in person i think now there is going to
be an interesting opportunity
rej i have so much that i wanted to talk
to you about i'm already upset that
our 20 minutes is up so first of all
thank you for coming thank you for being
here i know how busy you are
i think what you're doing is incredible
i think it's it's innovative
it's right on time and that's definitely
where the future is and i'm i'm
personally inspired by your own passion
for solving meaningful problems through
data i i
really that's the way that i see things
and i just loved hearing you talk about
that
before we leave i have to ask you the
most important question three words that
you would use to describe yourself
first principle thinker first principle
thinker
vijay thank you so so much and stay safe
and stay healthy